let us hop into this shall we what's up
guys I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey hi
I'm PJ Campbell I'm new here thanks guys
PJ Campbell's voice I have a voice I do
I have a voice and a face hoarse so arm
and a podcast boy screen podcast didn't
we talk about that once yes yes the
podcast will I do so this is a video
podcast we're doing right now
I was on PJ Campbell's podcast recently
and I saw this guy's video collection
we're gonna talk about a lot of bond
related stuff and I was like I need to
find someone to bring on here who knows
a lot about bond and I just he was the
only person I texted and he just so
happens to be a big bond fan yeah I
don't know perfect guy looked out yeah
felt really unfortunate I got this text
message he's like hey can you like come
over and talk bond man I don't like
hanging out with you that much but if if
you need it I'll come over
I appreciate that penny Jay guys I met
PJ through we both John and I both did
through the Schmo down and what do you
do there again I help behind the scenes
I shoot some of the behind the scenes
stuff I've helped write questions I've
met these idiots there John you're such
a lovely person how do you hang out with
him so often oh you know I take a lot of
drugs in the morning to get past the
initial you know Greg barrier and then
the rest of the Damned and sort of a
weirdly lucid dream state that feels
very profit is never appreciated in his
own land people we're gonna talk about
some fun things here one of our top
reward tiers at patreon is whatever
video you're requesting was put up on
the youtubes and we like doing like live
streams and podcast stuff now and today
comes from Mikael Linden handsome man
from Sweden and basically we've never
had a third person on for a podcast this
is kind of strange man so I'm the first
you're the first we're about to discover
how hard it is to stick to a time with
three of us we got to it the main topic
of the video are we recording yes we're
on this hey am I supposed to have a
podcast voice nah man
well do or do it our voice you want
these PG camp let's use it the podcast
boys guys I'm bringing energy to the
room that or something very breathy
while we discuss like history or the
supporting characters aspect okay so he
basically want us to talk about I have a
message right here that pretty much laid
it out enough in a real simple term that
I just did not pull up properly but kind
of just comparing the mission impossible
franchise to the Bond franchise and our
thoughts on both kind of going back and
forth which one we prefer he had a
couple of specific ones topics in
regards to it that I do want to cover he
was he was pretty much talking about
like this bond if it in today's society
what will happen to Mission Impossible
after Tom's a Parker
anyway I'll lead the charge here on
asking first I think I have John's
answer you probably prefer the mission
impossible franchise nowadays yes when I
was a kid I was all about bond PJ so
it's kind of a tough question because
the Bond franchise as a whole is many
different franchises kind of rolled
together currently mission impossible as
a franchise has six really great films
for the most part outside of Mission
Impossible - yeah so in that regard I
think it's almost the better franchise
because longevity-wise I think it's
almost had better movies overall it's
better constant yeah whereas bond over
time we have 24 official Bond films and
some of them are really great and some
of them are really awful and we've
really only had one fairly awful Mission
Impossible movie versus the five really
great ones you see I'm not as
well-versed in the Bond franchise of
light timing which is why you're here no
great because I've seen a handful the
Sean Connery ones I've seen maybe a
couple of Roger Moore ones and I've seen
all the Pierce Brosnan and all the
Daniel Craig ones and the thing is
Mission Impossible that franchise
actually gets my heart pumping sometimes
definitely whereas the Bond films other
than a couple of them like Casino Royale
is the only one that like oh yeah like
Skyfall was really cool the first time I
saw it it is not aged as well but yeah
then you Rory watch you're like that's a
good Bond movie yeah
Casino Royale is like the stand out to
me added them all and to me I think
because kicking off with like this bond
fit into today's society I don't think
he quite does which is a big reason why
Spectre seemed to be [ __ ] weird when
that how and they were I remember being
in the theatres and a lot of people
laughing very uncomfortably what he was
like you know about to bone Monica
Bellucci oh yeah oh like after her
problem the biggest problem with Spectre
overall and I think you might be right
in a way is that bond as a character now
in what we saw in like the Connery and
Roger Moore once he really doesn't quite
fit that's why Casino works so well
because Royale is a fresh take on a
character and it didn't fit the confines
of what the series had been so that for
me I think that's the biggest difference
when I feel like the first fresh take is
always the most special in a contained
franchise like this because the problem
that Casino Royale presents is okay now
how do we give everybody that rush again
coming back to this same tone you know
even though it is a new tone and they're
gonna get used to it again again you
know it's like I'm aware that bond came
before mission impossible and that
because I did a movie fights episode
where a mark and Draco and I were going
back and forth on like who's better
Ethan Hunt
or James Bond and yeah I agree that like
because James Bond is more of an
archetype and less of a full-fledged
character other than like before we
started filming PJ was saying how he
thinks that you know Daniel Craig was
the first time you got to be a full
three-dimensional character which I
agree with but even he but still to a
lesser extent than what Ethan Hunt has
become so the Bond franchise has that
that benefit of you can kind of just
keep this franchise going because of its
lack of depth yeah which is kind of
weird because of that lack of depth you
can keep this going forever as its as
it's proven to go but because of that
and I'm a guy who tends to go off of
more than just thought I go off of how
something moves my heart and Mission
Impossible is the one that connects with
on an emotional level I'm sorry for part
three yeah well yeah and I think the
thing that helps with Mission Possible
especially for the three of us is it has
been a kind of the gold standard of
action franchises for us growing up like
it Amy in our lives since we were young
don't get me wrong we had bond also but
Ethan Hunt has always been like the hero
for us and as we've gotten older Ethan
has gotten older so we've stayed with
him and it's always been Tom Cruise and
I think that's why we are still so
attached to it
bond again has changed so many times
there's been so many actors involved you
don't get that same attachment
especially because he never really grew
as a character he never grew Rosica yeah
one there's something that's interesting
to me about the franchises versus one
another because I think Mission
Impossible also forced bond into a weird
position because bond movies have action
but once you grow up and stop being 10
to 14 years old you start to realize
like oh the point of these movies is not
necessarily gadgets and action it's just
that those are elements that come along
with the espionage and the mystery and
all the different characters and stuff
like that and so I feel like now there
is an added pressure for Bond movies to
be a lot like a Mission Impossible some
gravitas yeah exactly and I feel like
that's just yeah weird identity crisis
for them because yeah part of it is it's
episodic and it's kind of like a TV show
where at the end of every episode we
just reset and I almost feel like bond
could have more longevity in the now if
we go back to embracing the fact that he
doesn't at least need to be on
serialized journeys because each Bron
you know is adapted or was adapted from
a novel and I got imagine each time you
would check in with him it's just a
different moment in his life they don't
have to be connected necessarily and I
feel like that is a way in which bond
could push away from being in Mission
Possible shadow because those are so
very connected
well weirdly I think that I mean what
influenced the the Daniel Craig ones was
actually the Bourne films more than the
Mission Impossible films especially
shows the Quantum of Solace we're
actually kind of going off of what
Casino Royale had done yeah exactly yeah
we're like mishmash of influencing one
enough right yeah
remember one mission impossible 3 came
out they were convinced it wasn't even
gonna do that well because that was
right after Tom Cruise jumped on the
cash and it was the lowest performing
with a that's right lost his contract to
Paramount yes and then those protocol
they were trying very very hard to get
rid of him yeah that was yeah but
between what Casino Royale did leading
to quantum leading to Skyfall Mission
Possible did the same thing where the
serialized storytelling started to
become important yeah and Ethan started
to grow as a character and I think that
in the long run it's worked much better
for Mission Impossible see like as a
Content word a contained franchise
Mission Impossible
I think it's stronger but the thing is I
don't I really have a hard time seeing a
continuing once Tom Cruise is gone I
have which is just kind of sad because
there was the show which was a nun Samba
piece and then I remembered the movie
upset a lot of people the first one
because they can't wipe down the example
and you made it the Tom Cruise show but
then the Tom Cruise show really became
awesome around part three because one
wanted to I liked one I really
appreciate one I really don't like part
two at all part three I that is my
personal favorite I felt like that's
when I like film love with not just
Ethan Abu Tom Cruise was that movies and
James is the director JJ Abrams Burton
Tom Cruise specifically sought him out
for that that's when it really became
like something special that franchise to
me because every time I watch that one
gets my heart pumping you know like when
he's running at the end you're like
[ __ ] run man oh my god he's so good
yeah that opening is incredible but a
big part of the franchise that has
because part three doesn't really offer
this but once you get to Ghost Protocol
and the other ones and I imagine for the
next two that they have going a big part
of the selling gimmick of the Mission
Impossible franchises what is the next
crazy stunt Tom Cruise is going to if
the movies were only that I would
probably wouldn't love them because I as
I feel like that's a weak argument that
people make against it they're like oh
all the people care about is a son Tom
Cruise is gonna be I'm like no that's
not true otherwise they would just wait
for it to go on YouTube and you'd watch
it because the movies are so much more
than those Tom Cruise stunts but those
are such a big factor in those movies
entertain because beyond him jumping off
of [ __ ] it's also the motorcycle chase
sequences you know these really
drawn-out sequences of
and if you eliminate Tom Cruise from
data you put in a stunt double or
someone who just doesn't have that level
of energy it's it's my imagination
the thing to help save bond because I
don't think the bond archetype works
anymore of sexist misogynistic alcoholic
who you know he's got all these like
terrible claws and also I just don't
think he's a good spy yeah I really
don't he blows [ __ ] up all the time I
mean that's actually kind of the point
though that was in Casino Royale he was
supposed to be a blunt instrument which
is understandable he was never supposed
to be a great spy he was kind of
terrible at what he did but the problem
was is that he always got the job done
in the end which is the problem that M
has always had yeah bond is always the
loose cannon he basically he's Martin
Riggs
if Martin Riggs was mi6 he's a terrible
he's got because he doesn't grow as a
character see Martin Riggs of these kind
of grow in this war but but bond doesn't
get to grow and because of that I think
what we saw in Spector had a lot of
off-putting things like when I go back
and watch their Sean Connery movies it's
a little uncomfortable to see just how
he treats and this isn't me just making
some like oh Greg's trying to hop on the
so fabulous acts you know social justice
warrior it's just facts at this point
it's [ __ ] bizarre yeah and that was
one of the main awkward things about the
most recent Bond film was they tried to
kind of split the difference and bring
back some of that old like yeah fun
suave stuff that isn't suave anymore and
I feel like that if you're talking about
bond for the now my take would be use
that then and actually confront it
rather than just trying to kind of put
it in or out of the character yeah
because that's what Casino Royale sets
up and everything after a casino has not
followed through with what they set up
yeah even even Spectre we watched we saw
video John and I have
of top ten movies where characters don't
have an arc and they brought up Skyfall
and I'm like that's so true Skyfall sets
him up for this like crazy ass character
re and he doesn't he doesn't have an art
kit all he learns nothing in the movie
it is nothing there's an arc he's that's
that's the topic of the video they
characters who learn nothing heroes and
he doesn't learn anything and I think do
you know that old bond theory of every
double of sevens and you double it as a
new bond it's a codename I feel like
that's actually the way you can save the
franchise is if you start implementing
that element and you stop doing as well
I mean for me I would stop doing as much
longevity with the different bonds and
switch amount more frequently so that
you can get a different kind of story
more often like I feel like bond could
have a place now if they went a bit
further away from Bourne and Mission
Impossible you don't try to do as much
gritty hand-held world domination I mean
like world domination is always involved
but if you take it in the more elegant
direction and in the more intellectual
side of espionage yeah I feel like then
you could actually make something to
sneaked out of it again
think you're completely right and I
think that's why at the end of the day
the 60s Bond films and even some of the
early 70s ones they are still so beloved
because I think that they'd still leaned
into that kind of sexier side of it
yeah I mean we don't necessarily get a
character out of it but it's suave its
sophisticated like the fight scenes
they're great but you like bond because
he's suave and he gets the girl and he
gets to be a badass well yeah it should
be oh [ __ ] he's about to use a gun or a
gadget not right is he gonna use a gun
or get right yeah I feel like especially
the further we've gotten into the recent
bonds you know there's a lot of emphasis
on that kind of stuff well and I think
again that's probably why we all like
Casino Royale so much and we keep
pointing to it is that is the movie that
is the best balance of everything and we
have never reached that again which is
why I think bond 25 is seemingly keeps
having all these stall out problems no
one can figure it out yeah nobody knows
where to go yeah well I feel like Daniel
Craig wants to put a closing stamp on it
and kind of bring in full circle from
Casino Royale and and I feel like
there's the there's the artists struggle
with that and then there's probably the
producer this is my theory is that
there's a producer struggle of well we
don't want to light and
you know we're gonna we still want to
end in the where we can keep this [ __ ]
going right even if you're not in it
right dan you like the Simpsons that's
what but that's the that's the issue
that it lends itself to like what I'm
getting with the Mission Impossible the
two sequels are gonna do back-to-back
which I'm gonna put it out there I'm
actually very trepidatious about that
yeah yeah because what what has made the
mission impossible franchise so
fascinating because it took like fast
and furious five movies to get it right
who or Mission Impossible took three
yeah where's like the first one's cool
second one's terrible throw one the guy
you know and with what it's always made
them special is they do it they put all
their focus into one [ __ ] movie they
release the movie and then they get back
to the drawing board it's started again
when are your doing two back-to-back I'm
like that's it's gonna be a little
excessive and you even hear like the
Russo brothers speaking out about it
never seems like a pleasant experience
when they decide to do that back-to-back
and they seem to lose something almost
every especially lately yeah last one I
did it well was freaking Lord of the
Rings but think of every other franchise
that has done it we haven't seen an end
game yet so we just don't know but you
know I think about the Matrix films kind
of the carribean Hobbit films any of
those young adult like any time you do
those back-to-back that tends to lessen
something and I feel like that's such a
daunting task that it's I'm personally a
little trepidatious about and I'm doing
two two together not just that the
series is not and this is not a dig at
Christopher McQuarrie by the way I love
him as a director I love him as a writer
I love my Sam man who that's fair I love
I will say one thing that the mission
impossible franchise had that was part
of its DNA for so long was different
directors coming in and leaving their
own stamp as well yes and we're gonna be
in a very different franchise by the
time this is over with eight where
McQuarrie will have done four of the
arrow B's and that's like a very
different side of this franchise at that
point which was a director driven
franchise - a writer driven franchise
and I have to think he wants to do
something
and I like to believe that he has a
story that he wants to do for this but
he I also know that he wrote most of the
script for Fallout in rotation while
they were still shooting so what kind of
franchise to do and what it like what
does that say about it and that's a very
interesting kind of thing to be looking
at and that gives me those pirates three
kind of vibes where it's like we're
making it up as we go what's the worst
that could happen pirate story can
happen yeah especially with a movie
series like Mission Impossible where all
those details you got to keep an order
like that sounds like a very daunting
way to make a movie like that and yet
says face that back to back it's like as
a consumer of media I used to be excited
by the prospect of getting more of
something faster and nowadays I am very
wary of that because more at an
accelerated rate almost always means
some kind of thing will be you know
missing from this or watered-down out of
this not that they can't get it but yeah
I feel like Christopher Nolan had the
right idea with his Batman movies which
is take your time and do something else
to scrub your palate because those
movies are like Mission Possible movies
will consume your life for the time that
you're making them they also might
consume Tom Cruise's life by the time
we're done with yeah it's kind of weird
because I I wish the mission impossible
franchise could go on without Tom Cruise
but I have the hardest time and I feel
like they're gonna try yeah they're
gonna give it a shot but who they're the
Tom Cruise is a rare it's like it's like
trying to take a Jackie Chan franchise
specifically and then not do it with
Jackie Chan who's known to do the stunts
you know and Tom Cruise you take that
out of there it's you have to get Dwayne
Johnson yeah Wayne Johnson can have jack
reacher
but the thing is crews you can have Tom
Cruise that his age dude the the last
mission impossible with the craziest
stunt ever and be like [ __ ] you your
friend do your own stunts mr. wrestler
guy and then I'm sure he would rise to
that challenge you know I know that he
wouldn't want to feel like you would I
prefer the Ethan Hunt character overall
as opposed to James Bond because at what
you get from casinos like the what are
the two character defining ones from
the franchises here Casino Royale and
you get Mission Possible three and if
you just look at those two movies you
see that Ethan Hunt is a very different
spy as opposed to James Bond where even
hunt is a character who really cares you
know like a lot of him is based off of
love that's like the major difference is
like in that movie he wants to say Keri
Russell because that was a student and
you know you loved her but not in like
oh you know I want to sleep with her but
like a father-daughter type of thing and
then the michelle monaghan side i love
themI and everything about it you even
get like nuggets of it and fallout where
the cop late female cops gonna get
killed and it's like even though he has
a much bigger mission at hand he can't
let this innocent person die whereas
bond is kind of like I'm gonna shoot
everyone and everything and blow up
whatever and I'm gonna sleep with
whomever you know that mission based
tunnel vision yeah you get the sense
Ethan's doing this for kind of the good
of the world and bond just has his
particular job it's it's kind of weird
because I feel like Casino Royale
despite that being my favorite Bond
movie is part of what might actually
kill the franchise well I think that's a
hundred percent accurate it was the one
thing that they decided was that bond as
a character needed to be interesting so
everything that they did was tied back
to his past and that is destroyed what
they were doing like Spectre is a slog
to get through because you're like wait
so Blofeld was just his stepbrother yeah
freaking kidding me
it makes no man no sense and the thing
is is like the bond art types is what
allows it to have such longevity because
of that lack but but then it's a weird
thing when you introduce the emotional
depth you can't keep that going for a
long time right because I'm even even
with the mission French sorry John it's
like last thing I'll say it's like not
even with the mission franchise part
three's the most personal one but now is
that after that it's like they're still
emotionally intense but they're nowhere
near as personal and it has to be that
way in order for the franchise to keep
go right and bond just can't seem to
find out because they went so [ __ ]
dark you know it's like you can't go you
can't just go back to bright bond after
the hata you know
see I think bonds fascinating because I
don't know what the rules are anymore
because half of me has been sitting here
during this talk going well just
Halloween it just just make a sequel and
go the other ones Africa scene around
didn't happen and this one's a direct
sequel to Casino Royale yeah and you
know we'll get it there but I think the
thing about bond that I think it's like
it was a cool idea to make him a
developed gritty three-dimensional
character sure but I think the strengths
that we discovered because of that is
the fact that it's okay I think that
bond is this cipher of a character
because the point I guess would be that
the villains in the world domination and
these side characters are what makes
each movie like the way a superhero
franchise is kind of hard to maintain
with the hero at the core being
interesting every time whereas the
villains are always more interesting and
stuff like that and bond has always been
partly about you know these eccentric
villains with these eccentric schemes
and so I feel like with those nuts and
bolts you can totally still do bond it's
just you have to the biggest obstacle
for me is yeah just the stuff that is
like dated in a bad way yeah you know
and I think it's interesting because we
kind of joked about the rock and The
Fast and the Furious but there's
something to say about the fact that
Fast and the Furious is a franchise has
become more emotionally investing as his
franchise said it is characters than the
Bond franchise ever has and there eight
movies in with a spin-off at a ninth
movie on the way and they're doing what
Mission Impossible did when they're
growing on top of it I think fate of the
Furies took a dip with audiences because
they tried getting the gravitas well
it's it's not the way you keep franchise
it's weird it's like guys watch this for
me I'm all about death but for certain
franchises sometimes when you try to
infuse that as your main thing and keep
that going it actually slows down the
enthusiasm of the franchise like what
when did because the thing with those
Fast and Furious movies prior to five
were man they were like melodramatic
boring and I thought they were boring
and melodramatic like especially the
fourth one [ __ ] is so heavy don't they
and then part Father like now let's just
have fun and then they kept that fun
going and the fate of the Furious was
like oh man Vin Diesel's really trying
to win an Oscar for some reason
and Hobson shot her like yeah that's
more and that's I think one needs to try
to find a way to get there I am
because Mission Possible has maintained
that fun feeling - exactly like that's
what we need out of these franchises we
don't need it to always be this grueling
character arc and I kind of
unfortunately a lot of this falls on
Nolan and I don't blame no one as a
filmmaker but Batman Begins before that
lessons we learn from yeah yeah like
every studio was like we have to make
the next Batman Begins we have to make
the next Dark Knight so heads Casino
Royale and Skyfall both being those
movies and I would much rather have bond
where it's kind of fun again like Casino
Royale is dark but it's fun and that's
where Craig is piqued and you can temper
it too cuz like they keep making these
movies so you could have a fun one here
in the dark one there and and you know
you can again I feel like it would be a
good idea to change actors more
frequently because then you can cover up
the lack of interesting bond character
notes with just what each person brings
to the role yeah and I think the bought
franchise is slight it was slightly
confusing at first when you watch casino
and then Skyfall because it's one of
those weird prequel movies but it's
modern-day time yeah it's kind of
strange and I like because when they
even when they try to introduce to me
one of the more the more interesting
origin was actually what they did with
ray Fiennes as em which then they didn't
fall through with well inspector but
when you see that when if you know
doctor know and then you will see em and
I like him evolved into becoming em and
Skyfall you're like oh that's just
[ __ ] cool they do that yeah have a
sweet but they don't really fall through
with it with any impact and yeah I think
through talking this through it's like
that's what Mission Impossible has done
so well they had a really heavy film
with part three but they managed to
figure out the right tone cuz what they
do in the park through is heavy that
Park for was the most fun you've ever
had your life fine looks like no we're
now we're gonna Mick we're gonna
mishmash
I think fallout and rogue nation both
did a good job of taking tones of
three and four and putting them together
in one blend because it feels personally
intense but also a lot of fun well it
changes you to that a lot of things can
there are different ways to give weight
and intensity to your action espionage
movie other than like Mission Possible 3
does do a very personal character driven
Ethan Hunt story but you don't have to
do that to have that level of stakes and
emotional intensity yeah there are other
things there are other themes you can
touch on there are other contexts and
situations that doesn't just have to be
this character is personally having a
very [ __ ] up experience yeah and it's
interesting too when you think about
casino right out of quantum like it's
very much the a through-line story like
yeah because quantum picks up right
where it left off fallout
picks up not long after rogue nation and
does the same thing but one of these
movies is much more successful at making
us care because it still has that
emotional weight to it yes so being
really fulfilling but it's not like
filled with like emotional weight which
is why it's such a great kind of cap 2 3
and they all started there yeah exactly
but I mean yeah overall I feel like mish
it's weird I prefer the mission
impossible franchise I don't think he
can continue on without Tom Cruise even
though they're gonna try and I think
bond is so close that my thoughts I feel
like you would need to kind of really
change up who bond is especially
nowadays cuz alcoholic womanizing son of
a [ __ ] just wouldn't work well today
and it's old it's done and it's like
because the way that women are all over
you especially the older films were
ready and we're very much like oh I just
always fall for bond you know yeah I've
seen plenty of articles I like right up
I like keep practically assaults this
girl right here you know so that a lot
of it and I felt that way with Spectre
and that's I'm like you really take
advantage of a grieving woman right
there so uh yeah I think you need to
change it up but and I need some bring
back the fun maybe what it needs to do
is do a movie that's actually like a
period piece maybe it would be better to
put back and bond back in like the 50s
or the 60s yeah and like rebuild it from
there believe you dream like a graphic
novel or a comic book
like that's how you do boy yeah that's
why it works the best Bond stories right
now
actually are being told in the comics
right now so you guys should check those
out
but legitimately it almost might be
better to move backwards and start fresh
there because a lot of what you're
talking about might be it's still not
acceptable obviously but yeah being able
to swallow it a little bit better if you
could mix a dash of what Mad Men has in
its sureness where it's like we're gonna
show you how people behaved but you
understand that Oh things were different
that's why I think if you if you take
the ways that all these bomb people are
the same but you just make the double-o
an identity I feel like that was that's
for the saving grace to it yeah I I
actually think that might not be the
worst way to end Craig's run this has
the mantle right yeah I'm trying to get
you man one of these has got to fail but
looking back at it it's kind of funny
because on her Majesty's Secret Service
which a lot of people know is the one
off like the one-hit wonder bond with
Georg Liza yeah they make a joke in that
movie about well this never happened to
the other guy so I kind of have always
had an ongoing joke about that idea of
maybe it is maybe it's yeah so why not I
mean at this point it might not be the
worst idea at least take the gamble
bring back Sean Bean double O six
spin-off series do this that was
beautiful yeah that was nice right we
started off a little rough kind of like
a franchise then we eventually found our
groove about two-thirds of the way it
was great fun podcasters so it's coming
from you that means a lot
all right guys well you should follow PJ
Campbell on the PJ Campbell show go
check out my episode I did with him and
Patrick Hogue who do you guys prefer
bond or mission impossible if you saw my
movie fights I believe that audience
voted for may have won that round that's
the correct answer that's a crazy
opinions our objective at least this one
this one specifically specifically and
anything I think subscribe to the reject
nation
click that notification Bell check us on
patreon and Mikael Linden my man thank
you so much for requesting this buddy
this video is dedicated to you my friend
he's a handsome Swedish guy you look at
him look at him look at that guy's
handsome he is
he should be in a Mission Impossible
movie he should write he could be a
villain you're the new Q let's do it the
new toy at us we will start this grow
leaning we will make this happen I
thought this guy was like 28 years old I
found out he's I can't find it he's 65
years old if I'm not mistaken 40 40 dude
I thought he's the perfect age to fight
even up on the Space Needle Rory's gonna
jump off next see you guys